welcome into this video playing friend
Jay and I've let him number of times
before he's also doing videos not not
necessarily on youtube I think it from
fall for some other forces for a forum
site maybe one of the the US can post
some information where he is active yeah
this castling was rather early yeah I
need to go F for if I don't play afford
this is completely toothless so on I'm
trying to get ahead to that form maybe
maybe I should have played night h4
actually maybe this would have been
better yeah he can even consider g5 you
know or that one okay I cannot lose any
more time here if he takes on h3 so be
it
maybe every show I've got two inch form
and now i have f5 I thought or queen G
fries the Sun I can also take on e5 and
this is the word slightly strange but
why not actually I'm just attacking here
and play Knight d2 292 to see form this
is an excellent square if it goes
tonight f1 Knight to c4 should be quite
good taking e 5 and therefore i can take
on age 3 but it's not really great
yeah this seems to be fine for what this
is just such a strong piece on c form
and his bishop is potentially really
weak maybe this is the key to the
position Bishop e7 to g5 i think i'm a
maybe should have done that check hmm
yeah decide didn't expect at all the
question is I could go to g2 as well
it's probably better way ticket so that
black is really immediately forced to go
night f4 yeah all Nigeria but then i can
take play 95 Bishop g5 takes 95 and then
f7 is just exploding and this is the
general problem he can he can play night
at four but i'll just take twice and how
do you how do you continue with this
pressure against f7 yeah I'm still
surprised that he's not moving out Nyjah
five was really too terrible maybe 95
maybe this was an idea okay but it's not
it's not decisive for sure okay the
question is a five or not yeah probably
five hmm yeah the g file so let's err
let's get rid of the Queen's as I'm
really looking forward um check to play
this ending he's got five week pawns and
I I have a good structure the four
points here on the queenside and the
soul h2porn but he's got only witnesses
throttling rookie seven
check Kim
with the king
yeah why not okay guys maybe this every
Scott rock g8 and this is Sam this is a
bit tricky look h5 rook g8 this kind of
a scandal idea
hmm this may be was not right you know
getting the kingdom okay probably rook
g3 to take care of that
rook GA drug g3 and the figures the
check i go back to g2 and have rook g3
ready yeah then I really need to go to
h3 it's really a somewhat unlikely spot
now but it's not moving and he's got
really problems to two planes it's not
easy at all you know this is probably
one of what I will have played as well
yeah I'm taking if I taking now tip 1
takes 95 this is the only reason why I
even considered this
maybe just just improve it I'm not quite
sure how to how to get some substantial
progress
mmm if I go here yeah just the tech f6
yeah look at six days rook h2 mate this
is how to be avoided check again and
this is this is also not easy I didn't
manage to to keep the night against the
bishop it's still a very very nice
position of course okay rook g2
hmm time warnings not it's no made real
name check check check check I know not
I wanted to give the check check check
check check check check black forfeits
on time yeah I one probably saw a master
winning I don't know i made the almost
the most sleep here here i wanted to
give this check chanted sir it's a made
him this is what I what I wanted to do
this is late and do this is Jack was
also seven eight and then hit then I
played rook takes a certain accidentally
yeah no it doesn't belong me to take
back move strange okay so let's stow
let's go i cannot draw arrows here this
is lifted from the magic yeah i think
around here i'm really in good shape he
probably should take on there for him
take on i cannot draw him for whatever
reason you should probably take on a
form and this now is just just very nice
for wide check check yeah yeah Knight e5
is also also news and even the bottoms
wow yeah i briefly thought about that
and then I thought okay take on air for
its good anyway but 95 is much better
it's a shame that I cannot really put
this on the board for some reason them
this is this is screwed up probably
because there's a made on
what this always seems to irritate the
software but i can i can try to explain
anyway 95 gains the tempo on the Queen
the Queen moves and then Quint x f4 and
how is he going to save f7 is probably
impossible I'm just winning an important
temple yeah this was letting something
slip here I mean okay queen air for what
I played is also very good for wide but
the other is probably better okay thanks
for watching